- Même en pleine pandémie,
ça fait partie du style de vie
d'une des villes les plus
modernes et branchées de l'Inde,
Bangalore : déguster une bière
artisanale en bonne compagnie.
(rires)
Martin Bernard dévoile
fièrement à ses amis brasseurs
canadien, allemand et indien
sa toute nouvelle création :
une bière au melon d'eau.
MARTIN BERNARD,
maître brasseur, Brahma Brews
- Le palais indien est pas
très... accommodant avec
ce qui est très amer,
donc le sucré, ça passe,
le fruité, ça passe.
- Ce natif du Québec est,
en quelque sorte, le parrain
de la microbrasserie en Inde.
Il est arrivé à Bangalore
il y a huit ans, alors
qu'il n'y avait qu'une dizaine
de microbrasseries.
- Ouais, c'est une fierté
d'être là depuis le début, de
voir aussi que, de plus en plus,
les gens font la différence
entre une bonne bière et
une mauvais bière, aussi.
- Bangalore, la Silicon Valley
de l'Inde, compte des milliers
de jeunes riches professionnels
locaux et d'expatriés en quête
de brasseries artisanales.
En quelques années à peine,
la ville est devenue la capitale
asiatique de la bière.
On compte aujourd'hui
une soixantaine de
microbrasseries dans cette ville
de 12 millions d'habitants,
malgré les ravages économiques
causés par la pandémie.
Mais les établissements ne
peuvent vendre leurs produits
que pour la consommation
sur place. Ils n'ont pas
l'autorisation d'embouteiller
leurs bières ou d'offrir
des produits à emporter.
- Moi, je vais faire
une bière à la mangue...
- André Leblanc est
originaire du Nouveau-Brunswick.
Il a longtemps été brasseur
en Belgique, avant d'arriver
à Bangalore, il y a cinq ans.
Il est le grand sage passionné
du milieu de la bière artisanale
indienne. Il adore les occasions
d'expérimentation dans
ce nouveau marché aux
possibilités infinies.
ANDRÉ P. LEBLANC,
maître brasseur
- Moi, je suis très dans
l'éducation de la bière.
C'est-à-dire que je suis
maître-brasseur par passion,
donc ça veut dire que j'aime
bien transmettre mon savoir-
faire aux autres, et en Inde,
ils sont avides de savoir.
- Martin Bernard a financé et
mis sur pied le seul laboratoire
indien pour la culture de
levure brassicole. Il rêve
de créer une souche indienne.
- Moi, je voulais comme
réussir à faire plus
de sortes de bières,
de variétés, avoir plus de
différences dans mes saveurs.
- André Leblanc et Martin
Bernard ont 1000 projets en
chantier, mais ils s'assurent
de trouver du temps pour
se rencontrer chaque semaine.
Une bulle canadienne
dans un pays complexe.
- On parle la même langue,
donc c'est un peu...
se retrouver entre...
en famille, quoi!
- Dans un marché en plein essor,
deux Canadiens, la tête remplie
d'idées, pilotent la petite
révolution de la bière indienne.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, B